[Music]
[Music]
fire
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby yeah we're good
I've decided that uh I had a guy who
said when I was in the Marines and we
were in the Ford operating base and life
was [ __ ] we would come back and listen
just to get a laugh and I you know what
I realized about podcasts in the what US
yes and what I realized about podcasting
is that you can like drop a bunch of
knowledge or you can make people laugh
which is more valuable yes you have 10
years right well because people tune in
not to learn but to laugh because
laughter is more important than anything
else when you're going through some [ __ ]
and that's why they tune to us that's
why they explained us now how many I've
been marching that down your old let me
weathered throat let me explain the
[ __ ]
um fermentation process please yes but
that's all I go but we've had people on
uh yeah same thing there's a guy he was
like oh during in Boston he's like yeah
man during uh during the pandemic he was
like I'm still at home with the kids man
I just put your [ __ ] on my wife was like
you guys were the only thing that kept
us going like there you go there you go
there you go there you go you're not
coming there's here's the thing I don't
listen this might surprise a lot of
people we're not the smartest cats in
the bunch they're smart so if you can
give a hot take on the current climate
between Russia and we ain't the guy
crane we ain't the guy we might throw
some jokes at it sure we're gonna have a
funny take on it sure we'll probably
talk about Putin's big old angry Russian
dead yup that's it but you're using us
for straight up information correct God
bless you know what what worked on me
with Putin a long time ago him posing on
a horse with his shirt off I knew that
would work and I was like you know amen
you know well I'm gay man but also I was
like that's a very manly thing we would
never have a president do that and and
then there was a picture of him holding
a baby tiger
that was before he invaded Ukraine and
uh also the Judas uh Judo stuff too we
saw him yeah people are like well crazy
yeah here's the thing imagine if I if
you we were somewhere and I was like oh
dude I'm taking my shirt off and jump on
this horse everyone go don't do that
don't do that now Putin is I'm gonna do
this thing go yes sir well nobody oh no
that's sick because he's the he's the
most successful gangster in history in
history he's the most successful
gangster and the richest man in the
world if you actually think about it
you're sitting his crib yeah my God yeah
so but he's back yourself in a corner
here yeah they see some Yachts they see
some Yachts yeah it's tough
can't do that anymore we're gonna put
some pressure on on poot
well it's funny because uh people not
you know balls deep in like the Winter
Hill Gang and Whitey Bulger well I do
the meet and greets in Boston everyone
had a story and I loved I could I should
have done a Whitey Bulger gangster mafia
Boston podcast oh yeah everyone had
their story everybody oh they were good
yeah just epic stories he he uh he put a
lot of fear into people's hearts I mean
he's a yeah bad guy yeah FBI performant
and worked for the government all that
stuff I had a we stayed at a lake house
me and the boys you're in Tacoma I was
in Tacoma please say it correctly I was
in Tacoma and what a beautiful [ __ ]
lake house it was but you know something
when you go and get into a lake house at
night Bubba and you look around you're
like I the first thing I said the lake
was there the trees and I went well we
we're never getting out of this alive
oh yes I'm scared yeah I looked down in
the basement in the basement had a white
it wasn't our door just had a white
sheet covering it and I said that Nick I
go down there and he goes I'm not
[ __ ] going down there I go just go
down here's the bad news you'd have to
stay in the basement you got to stay in
the basement you got to stay in the
basement it was a beautiful house but I
was like I I don't know Lakes are Eerie
Lakes are a little Eerie that's where
ghosts Tacoma's cool though Tacoma is
you know what it's a perfectly it's a
you know what they're good it's a half
hour outside of Seattle yes that's
Tacoma is a half hour I'd rather be in
Tacoma in Seattle yeah so yeah I loved
it loved the crowds the trucking loved
the crowd traffic Daddy I told you this
last time I was there Tacoma if you go
to Seattle you know you want to go to
the Pike's Place and the first Starbucks
which is the traffic they can't expand
the roads because over water yeah so
it's you know talking about two-lane
highways yeah so the traffic is nuts yes
nuts yeah can't do it I I could live in
Boston I just can't do the I just can't
do cold if it was like fall somewhere
there all the time I could do it well
you know code from Denver but this cold
hurts your face to walk around not for
me this is I'm telling you January you
cannot walk around with your face
exposed for more than five minutes
because it's too cold for your [ __ ]
face you can't do it put your face in
ice water and hold it there and tell me
how it goes can't do it no we went to
that Union Oyster everyone until we go
to Union oysters the oldest restaurant
in Boston and they knew I was coming so
they set us up in uh JFK's seat because
you know he's a Massachusetts and even
when he's president that was his
favorite restaurant and he sit in the
corner booth and they have his picture
there then you could order drink we sat
there was that was cool because I love
that stuff I love that stuff I love it I
I I tried to walk a half a mile I had it
on my GPS I was in Boston in the winter
I didn't have a scarf and I had just a
down jacket and a sweater and I tried a
scarf though right a half mile you have
to in Boston sure and you have to have a
hat didn't have a hat a lot of problems
and I said let's see if I can handle
this
and I I darted into a [ __ ] store I've
darted and out of breath you're not
because I'm cold oh and I was panicked
and she goes the woman goes where's your
scarf where's your scarf yeah where's
your hat it's winner yeah and I was like
where can I buy one right now
I just can't do it if they didn't have
that I could live there what's it called
though when you were there no I mean no
there's some rain but still good though
it's still good yeah it's still all good
lap Boston great Club good club now that
used to be Southie Bubba you know that
that was like that area was South I had
a whole bit on it has changed how
Charleston changed from bankrupt what is
now yep yeah
it's just completely different now
completely different I want to do a club
because we always we've done Wilbur
together because I always do the Wilbur
out there I always want to do a Boston
Club so we did laugh Boston you drive by
The Wilbur the left Boston I drove by in
Texas I guess yeah and the line is two
miles long and I was like who the [ __ ]
is there so I looked up it was Neil
deGrasse Tyson yeah just one night in
that crate crazy he's on the same
circuit just selling a lot more tickets
yeah same age yeah yeah yeah crazy right
he's awesome he's interesting well it's
also encouraging that somebody can talk
about space and that many people wanna
you know I've never played so big you
know what I'm not interested in Everett
I never have been space I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm sorry I don't I I know it's
huge and amazing I just never cared
about if you say hey you know the cosmos
or Milky Way I'm already half asleep
I'm bored I'm bored yeah I think because
it's like yeah there's not much we can
do it doesn't affect me we're limited to
like knowing about it I don't know I'm
not that into it either Rogan is
obsessed with it he would always be like
we're a rock and if you look at the
infinite and I was like ah I don't care
assassin would like get horrible like
anxiety because you think of how
insignificant we are compared to the
grand scheme I don't know like the
Galaxy and stuff you remember that no
but I freaked out one time when I was
out I was like whoa that that's never
ran through my head yeah yeah now I can
help strategy for Seinfeld he talked
about that he's like if I get stressed
out I'd look at that map and go I'm
nothing yeah yeah that's a good way to
deal with it you know it doesn't work
for me that don't work for me it doesn't
work for me all those little tricks guys
uh when you go you know what I'm just an
insignificant piece no no no it doesn't
work for me no it's my hook up at the
cosmos doesn't work for me no I I none
of that works and here's the other thing
that doesn't work for me don't tell me
to just trust the universe because I
won't either because the universe is not
my friend it's not my friend universe
doesn't get I'm trying to kill you all
the time when I was hunting out in
Alaska you you I was wondering why and
Rogan was talking about it too and so is
ranella when you look out when you're
out on top of a glacial Lake and
nobody's around you get depressed you
there's a depression that sets in and
all of them all of a sudden because I
would look out and I would feel so sad
and the reason I felt so sad is because
I was in a place where I couldn't
survive and it didn't care about me and
and there's something about that where
you're just like by the way go down
there and look at how handsome I was
please go down there and look at how
handsome which one down to the corner
right there the only way he looks young
wow
good looking guy look at the hair on me
you [ __ ] [ __ ] the top the top is
still not great though right I got my
Lids the tops I'll take that top
There's No Gray Bubba when was that that
was two years ago
two years ago damn it well that's the
yeah the the universe doesn't give a
[ __ ] about ah [ __ ] about you well
through my way with you thing Brian
stop no do you think about that's my
thing even when like no even super
important this is a really depression
think when you know when somebody really
important passed away like when Kobe
Bryant died we were so upset yeah the
world gave everyone well this is what I
always say don't stop no matter who it
is I said this I go Queen Elizabeth's
got 12 days if a billion people die it'd
be the most worst thing ever God help us
if it ever happens but if it happened
way the [ __ ] over there way over there
we'd all be sad but nobody would miss
work
people supposed to do like everyone has
to take care of their own like granted
you want to take care of your own then
be you know nice and help people out but
you got to make sure your own house is
eating and it's warm and those kids have
clothes yeah so you're worried about
your own man yeah so when people die
it's like that's not my uncle yeah
that's not my they don't provide for me
I gotta do my thing yeah I see you keep
looking in the shirt Triple O's this is
Whitey bulger's bar I wasn't looking at
them no I saw you kept looking at its
bar you're a little bit like you want
one you're like a chick who who loves
serial killers and criminals like my ex
was that way she was so into it you you
have you have a lot of that oh yeah I'm
way too into it yeah hey B let's take a
little break buddy a little break buddy
I'll tell you we're uh people can take a
little break and see us do some stand up
if you want to laugh if you want to
laugh and hard if you like to laugh hard
and get your wieners out and have a
grand old time well I know you're going
to be in San Jose San Jose and probably
next week 13 14 15. that's next week
next week I'll be at the uh speaking of
which the Bridgeport Bridgeport
Connecticut Stress Factory October 13 14
15. this will be a nice flight to
Bridgeport dude
I love well I love that because I get to
take two take three and you do me a
favor yeah I'll take three planes and
then a shuttle I'm gonna drag to San
Jose that's next week October 13th the
15th and then Salt Lake City Wise Guys
October 20th through 22nd then I end uh
October in Calgary Calgary downtown
Calgary Alberta Canada Calgary at the
rooftop the show on the 27th almost sold
out so we added show on the 28th that's
Friday the rooftop trying to fly back on
the 29th through a fight campaign for
Jake Paul announcing Silva and Calvin
cater Arnold Allen keep you guys posted
I ain't telling 29th I'm Not Buddy on
the 29th I'm afraid I'm in Schaumburg
Illinois
Chicago improv but we know where that is
yeah we'll call it that October 27 28 29
I wish I was there Charlotte North
Carolina Comedy Zone November 10 11 12.
Naples Florida off the hook Comedy Club
December one two three and four I'll see
you there you got to protect yourself
and you got to protect yourself
physically and sometimes you got to
protect yourself when you're online dude
these days hackers you're talking about
cyber protection daddy listen listen
yeah that's the bottom line that's why
you need a vast it's the global events
the global leader in cyber protection
for more than 30 years they're gonna
shoot buy over ready for this 435
million users it prevents over 1.5
million attacks every million not
million but billion is that billion Yep
this is it empowers you to look it vast
empowers you to with digital safety and
privacy no matter who you are where you
are or how you can act you can enjoy
these opportunities that come with being
connected and on your terms yep a vast
new all-in-one solution a vast one helps
you take control of your safety privacy
online through a range of features all
right because of vast believes essential
protection should be available to just
not the rich but to everyone a free
version of avast one still includes
award-winning free AV free VPN free
firewall and much much more we got you
covered all right a vast premium version
has even more advanced protection and
allows you to protect multiple devices
that's the one I like to go with avas
privacy features keep your identity and
actions hidden nobody knows what you're
doing Daddy all right sure this is the
future VPN allowing you to connect
safely and secure public Wi-Fi like at
the airport Starbucks conduct your
business wherever you want without the
fear of a cyber and there are people out
there always looking to steal your data
always always oh dude that's a fact
whether you know it or not it's being
it's being taken from you avas also has
the ransomware protection secures your
personal photos documents other files
like emails from being modified deleted
or encrypted by some Ransom attacks we
got you man so if you're ready to go so
here you go man thanks aves for
supporting the fire and the kid all
right confidently take control of your
online world with avas1 it helps you
stay safe from viruses phishing attacks
ransomware hacking attempts and other
cyber crimes all right learn more about
avas1 at avas.gov that's
a-v-a-s-t-one that's spelled out o-n-e
guys listen
okay it's an app on my phone dude I'm 39
is it too late for me to learn Dude too
late for you to learn and you can have
you can take 10 minute lessons Okay
you're gonna real life conversations
with real people that can't take like
three years no dude you start learning
in as little as three weeks oh my God
you know other uh learning apps use AI
for the other one plans Babel was
created by 150 language experts I've
done a bunch of different apps I always
say this it's the best by far that's a
fact I use it actually all the time uh
and they they've got 14 different
languages in Spanish uh they got Spanish
they got French they got Italian they
got oh my God this is insane 10 other
languages dude if you say they give me a
20-day money-back guarantee I'm gonna
free I'm gonna give you that I'm Gonna
Give You speech recognition technology
to make sure that your pronunciation and
accent are good how about that and right
now you can get 55 off your subscription
when you go to
babblebabel.com fighter that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com fighter up to 55 off of
your subscription Babble language for
life I finished the dog I don't know I
bought a book this is why are we so in
the serial killer yeah I just got it
because they say about women
um women it's a way of of studying the
Demonic male they want to understand the
psychologist so they can predict his
behavior and stay away from him right
surprise same with me I I don't know I
don't know here's a weird outlet but
here's a weird thing about some women so
for whatever reason serial killers
gangsters there is a not an
insignificant number a portion of the
female population that's drawn to it and
wants to marry it and that so so
evolutionary biologists this guy was
talking about how it might be it's like
um there's a book called I think it's
the Demonic male can you look it up
about apes and it might be because they
represent such a far far extreme of the
genetic aggression code and then women
who are on the Other Extreme of the of
the passivity code
there's this weird uh attraction that's
supposed to create children that
ultimately become normal but here's the
thing here's the thing to debunk to
debunk that stuff don't get me wrong I I
think it's interesting I think because
it's so out of the norm when these guys
get away with it especially back in that
time period they would get away with
this stuff and it's just so insane
especially the way they did it and the
the people they would go for don't get
it twisted the oh the all these series
don't ever get twisted all these serial
killers are complete [ __ ] they go for
people that are you know that that need
protection they go they like the they
live with their moms and stuff yeah no
there's [ __ ] yeah they're losers
they're losers who decide to take the
easy way out there
I'm not a [ __ ] fan of anything it's
just to me it's so interesting like how
somebody can be that evil yes it's
insane to me but they're all coward but
here this book is about look at this I
didn't know this but humans are
genetically closer to chimps than chimps
are to gorillas I didn't know that did
you know that that's [ __ ] crazy and
the chimps and bonobos are more most
closely genetically related
um so they look at like how how violent
but also how kind certain apes are it's
a really it's a really interesting thing
yeah I don't know why I'm so into it I
don't I don't know what to tell you dude
I'm just super in the Charles Manson's
the most fascinating one it's not even
Syracuse yeah so so we label them so do
you think it's because you're um it's
you're do you want to have them do you
want to have sex with them I don't think
so but back to the point where women get
attracted to them like the night's
soccer if we're gonna go like First Team
all good looking serial killer yeah
Richard Ramirez number one we got his
teeth done right Ted Bundy close second
right did he get his teeth done uh the
The Night Stalker did yeah very bad he
got veneers yeah he didn't shower but he
got veneers in the street about my best
serial killer looking all the time
Charles Manson only five five if he's
taller he'd be up there look at him on
the left it's a demon on the right
you're like oh is that a Gucci model
right yeah he's a really good insane
yeah but that thing when they when when
the eyewitnesses like one lady survived
he shot her in the face and she survived
the first thing she said the detective
said this is strange the first thing she
said he was a very handsome guy who
tried it
it takes like what he was a very
attractive male which usually went out
with Syracuse the theme of John Wayne
Gacy like they look like [ __ ] look at
him he's such a good looking guy what he
was the worst of the worst but back to
so I finished that uh is he dead yeah
horrible death really yeah you got
disease in prison his skin turned yellow
and his eyes turned neon yellow and died
nobody got worse death than Jeffrey
Dahmer though right yeah you don't
happen to him no I don't oh he had
secondary beasts he looked insane yeah
so chronic substance abuse chronic
hepatitis C viral infection it was a
really bad death worm and that's what he
[ __ ] deserves that's right Jeffrey
Dahmer got the most satisfying death out
of any serial killer he got the [ __ ]
beaten out of him oh just to get the
[ __ ] beat him check this out so Jeffrey
Dahmer they they kind of loot to it in
the series why am I excited to hear this
oh it's so fast
I literally just went like this and I
sat back a little I'm getting crunched
my notes he made a good story why am I
this what that's interesting all right
check this out yeah and they allude to
it on the the series right and we'll
talk about that but I finished in two
days I got problems so 10 part series
two hour each is so well done and I want
to see the guy who killed him oh but let
me tell the story before the guy killed
him okay so Jeff stammer goes to prison
right yeah and he's in prison and he
like you said people are attracted to
that whatever reason they're fans he's
getting fan mail yeah and they're
sending him money he's autographed
things they're paying for his autograph
and this was before they passed the law
that you can't benefit off murder so
back then he's making money he's getting
all the treats all that [ __ ] and he
started to like feed into his own kind
of Fame he's like I'm kind of a
celebrity and this people treat me
different they would allow him to go
outside so I was pissing the other
cellmates off then he would eat lunch
and he would pretend he would like oh
this is like a finger and like oh this
is like that guy's liver that I ate and
he'd like play around with it well there
was a guy there a bad dude who's like
hey [ __ ] you think this is funny
quit doing this [ __ ] we don't like this
but he's been locked up so long he
wasn't aware of Jeffrey dahm I just
thought he was this white dude who was
[ __ ] weird so he goes to the the
person controls the library in the
prison and they're like you know because
of your condition you can't do this and
he goes but I'm right with the Lord now
I've been fine I haven't had any hiccups
for years can you just let me in look
into this Jeffrey Dahmer guy because I'm
worried he's gonna hurt somebody and the
lady was his friend he goes yeah let you
look he looks into it so he's killed a
14 year old boy I'd say this this all
this horrible [ __ ] he he ate people the
guy's a man of the Lord
and so Jeffrey Dahmer in prison all of a
sudden man of the Lord got baptized all
this [ __ ] right so Jeffrey Dahmer they
would allow him to clean the gym and I
think the the guards were in on it of
course so it's Jeffrey Dahmer and his
other buddy in prison the other buddy in
prison killed she killed his wife
stabbed her in the face blame it on two
black guys and those black guys went to
prison for a few years so they found out
that they actually did it this is
Dahmer's buddy so the guards bring them
to clean the gym
that guy was like no these boys ain't
getting away with this tough dude goes
in there the guard goes oh we have a new
uh man to the cleaning crew he's gonna
help you guys out tonight guard leaves
that guy goes looks like it's show time
he goes first on because the guy was
cleaning like the locker he was first
just destroys that guy bashes his head
and kills him goes to Jeffrey Dahmer and
he's like I'm the man the Lord and Dom
because I am now too he goes no you're
not he goes my Lord has Vengeance for
the stuff that you did and he goes he
goes I was reading did you kill a 14
year old boy and dominoes yeah I did you
know then you would eat him he goes yeah
I did and he goes well guess what
[ __ ] today's your Resurrection
Day today's when you pay the piper took
a [ __ ] first of all he punch him in
the face then he went and got a small
barbell
and he was like and he told Dahmer he
was like and you killed a 14 year old
boy [ __ ] and predominantly black
neighborhood you're killing blacks and
Dahmer goes yeah before he kills me goes
yeah but I would give them uh medicine
so they didn't feel it and he goes well
you're about to feel every single one of
these he literally beat his face into a
pulp so bad that they couldn't tell us
Jeffrey Dahmer after he was done yep and
he had another like two year life census
but when you hear that you're like
that's exactly how this should go
correct that's that's the universe full
circle wow bring up a picture of the guy
that murdered Jeffrey Thomas that
Vengeance killed Jeffrey Dahmer
that's a right that's what's called
that's what we call a righteous that's
what we call Justice we call a Righteous
Kill yeah he said his last words you're
about to feel he goes yeah but they
didn't feel anything it was cool you're
about to feel every single one of these
[ __ ]
man oh man this guy
yep
okay
yep
well Dahmer's uh killer Scarborough said
the serial killer taunted inmates with
food yeah you'd [ __ ] up their lunch and
be like look this was like the liver
that I ate from this victim and like you
know play those games yeah and those and
here that dude I had a life sentence I
was like [ __ ] it
uh Dahmer series is interesting
um if you haven't seen it yet I'm gonna
split for you a little bit in three two
one
in the series The Net so it's a
next-door neighbor the lady who kept
calling and calling and calling and
complaining of saying that power smells
horrible and I smell power tools and
then she'd go to Jeffrey Dahmer and he'd
like goats pork chops at my family
saying pork chops it went bad and
whatever people bought that
the truth is if we Jeffrey Dahmer's book
the detective that wrote it the series
has to do their job and make it
entertaining she actually lived in a
different building
shooting this next door neighbor the
next door neighbor never said anything
he nothing she actually lived in another
building across the street and would
watch him
she was just like you know she was just
she had nothing to do and she'd just see
him coming in and out all the time she
didn't live next door though that's my
only problem with the series but also
you know we've been around TV Hollywood
it's like well yeah they got to make it
interesting she can't be across the way
it doesn't make sense you know so she
wasn't her people that know the story
like this is ridiculous choosing the
next door neighbor I'm like but for the
entertainment made it so much better
because she could hear those guys
yelling screaming and the smell but if
they tried to do it the actual way where
she's in another [ __ ] completely
across the street dude not that close
that's the real
interesting huh yeah [ __ ] crazy dude
I watched that uh Marilyn Monroe the
blonde it's nc17 yeah the only reason I
watched for NC-17 oh yeah so halfway
through it there's some sex scenes where
I'm like it's pretty hot and the girl
playing is so hot right yeah
it's a it's heavy on abortion but and
people that are against abortion are
super mad at this movie like someone's
getting so much backlash it got a lot of
abortion she got a lot of abortions but
here's my thing she was also kind of
raped wasn't she a lot
um
or she had to have sex with all these
yeah like she got her start by having
sex and so she went in there to read her
first role she went in there and it was
like the head of whatever some big time
production company she wanted to do the
read even do the read he just had she
did it and they said cool had sex with
her she walks out crying and then day
later like you got the role and she's
like what that's how she got to start so
of course she's me [ __ ] up with that
but it being NC so the people who are
mad that there was you know the show the
abortions my caveat to that is but
that's her story should they ignore all
that yeah that's her story they showed
the story they're not the people that
made our anti-abortion that's just her
story yeah so there's you know there's
like four or five abortions in the thing
it's pretty heavy that thing and see
something you know like tits all that
stuff sex I'm like Nancy I was like I
don't even need to be on c17 and then
towards the end she pays a visit to my
boy JFK and he's in the presidential bed
right he's on the phone and he's talking
and she comes in and go sit down and
then uh he's on the phone with some big
you know Governor something and he just
gets to stick on shirts Jack him off and
like well this is pretty cool and then
he said come on come on baby he grabs
her head and it shows this is why it's
mc17 it shows up close her pretend to
suck JFK's dick I mean straight porno
style yeah like you can just see the tip
of the dick but her head's going up and
down Jesus and here JFK going yeah [ __ ]
you little dirty [ __ ] I was like oh
that's why this is Jesus but I'm
watching on the plane two old ladies
next to me oh no and I'm like yeah take
it oh no oh my God I go have you and I
know they saw it I went have you yeah
this Marilyn Monroe thing is sad don't
watch it it's just sucking dick I'll say
this thing's awful man I can't believe
they did this you believe that it's
crazy just play but rewind play that's
the problem with opening your phone up
when you have friends like Mine and Ours
you open your phone up and your friends
are going to send you stuff you don't
even know why our mutual friend of ours
sent me just I was on the plane open up
and it was a guy who this skinny white
dude with the biggest dick I've ever
seen just this huge heart on that's all
a picture was I was like hey people
think you're gay I'm on a [ __ ] plank
I was like erase erase we need you can
put those filters over it where people
can't see I never yeah haven't done it
like for example be ready for a disaster
earthquake I should be storing water I
should be storing food I should have
this I don't have that stuff I just
don't I get home I can roll the dice
yeah I should be doing all that [ __ ] I I
just never think about this I just don't
did a lot of gun shooting this weekend
when my buddy used to be a Delta guy and
he had me come out uh my buddy Tom and I
went out to his amazing he's in the
middle he's about an hour outside of
Seattle okay and uh in the woods where
there's nothing but like mountain lion
and bear and deer you can shoot him off
this there are problems up there yeah
but my but my man has
um all the guns right because he was a
Delta guy he's got all the guns he knows
his way so we went out and shot [ __ ]
it was really interesting shot uh AR-15s
shot sniper rifles shot 45s nine
millimeters everything now I'd never
done this though
so I'd never done what they actually how
they actually train so I can shoot
anything with an AR-15 because it's got
a laser and you can hit everybody just
hold the gun it's no kick yeah you got a
sniper rifle it's got more of a kick but
you can figure that out too
you got a pistol I'm a pretty good shot
with a pistol should I can group or you
know about whatever both my eyes open
okay group here's the thing dude then he
said okay now
you got the AR-15 now I want you to walk
towards the Target and try to hit it
just move a little just move a little
just walk so just move that's all it'll
just take Miss walking I didn't hit it
[ __ ] once you know why as you walk
yeah your body so you're I missed well I
missed a human body by I didn't hit it
once dude and none of us did except for
my buddy Nick actually ended up doing it
but but but it was really interesting
then with a pistol same [ __ ] he goes I
want you to walk towards and unload can
do it the the gun's going like this and
it smokes so you your your eyes are
squinting and it just I sucked I sucked
how long did you guys shoot for
long enough yeah one hour after after 20
minutes I'm all set here's the thing
about it if you're just a regular guy
like us when you shoot guns that are
that loud and that powerful it exhausts
you oh so because you don't you don't
realize it you're tense all the time and
then you're doing these drills where
you're trying to walk for and
everybody's competing with each other
yeah everybody's competing everybody
wants to shoot better we usually start
with like the Desert Eagle start with
the big guns AR-15s all that that's that
it's like what is there a bazooka
there's nowhere to go up from here yeah
okay yeah it's 15 minutes I appreciate
you guys yeah another time we shot and
the guy was like now I have to charge
you for the ammos
when you're doing when you're moving
it's not side to side when you're moving
toward when you're moving forward and
the way those guys do there's a whole
technique to that um just like anything
like anyone would assume like did you
see your boy uh Antonio Brown with his
big old Piper dick out at the pool stick
out what speaking of heavy artillery no
I'd like you just had a pool in Dubai
it's a family pool no hey it's not like
this wait a minute so he's got issues I
need to talk to you about Tua yeah yeah
please talk to me about two okay but
look at this
I'm surprised they don't have the the
well he's got issues yeah I want to know
who's filming what if it was friends
like yeah get your ass in her face
hold on I mean he's got a nice ass who's
this girl
yeah but apparently she's pissed about
it I just I think if you just close it
chin you can't close it that's not a
wake up go up see that thousand dollars
pay a thousand dollars
and apparently they say he's not happy
is what I'm hearing
thank you
oh she's moving away from bored
look not look that now he gets his dick
out oh they stopped it well that's and
it's like you know this you know the
submarines that come up and they gotta
look over the land yeah it's like
doesn't look like anybody's in the pool
but still like I mean she's in the pool
yeah he's got a dick and his defense was
awful
he was just trying to talk about two huh
you just start trying to take the
spotlight off him yeah he's like y'all
here worry about this big ass dick you
know what about he didn't say biggest
but he's like y'all wait y'all worry
about this what two of them man you're
like wait those are two different things
but yeah
yeah he's not doing well I'll find it no
that's that's arguably CT
because it creates no he but he's always
been crazy he's always been touristy
known to be out of control for a long
time I think we're gonna find out that
this so so but B this is what I don't
like I know that's why I don't and
everyone does this CT or he's always
been like this man or he's just crazy or
no or he's been he's been at Prince for
so long he's he's everybody's always
give tell he's always been
a guy that got a pass because he was so
talented correct right I don't know but
I will say this that um after two I
listened to there it is look at that
snout what the [ __ ] look at that pipe
okay
that's a giant and it looks like it's
not hard yeah it's hard to get it's hard
to get an erection it's pulling it up so
but even even stretch that's ain't
hardly stretched something out like a
[ __ ] bungee cord yes I'm impressed
yeah I mean to me yeah
I was like I got a dick on him was that
his girl or was that just some not his
girl apparently she's not happy okay
well she is not happy um is there uh
I I yeah that's interesting yeah all
right well but so this guy was talking
about who had got a traumatic brain
injury football player remembers that
Chris is his first name and he was
talking about wait in the NFL yeah and
he uh he had a traumatic brain injury
like like as in he went into this thing
and he sees that he said the problem
with that is when you get a traumatic
brain injury your incidence for suicide
and depression skyrockets depend who you
are yes well traumatic brain injury so
not everyone be so so there's this when
you get you do that and then there's
this and what Tua did was that and that
is a that is a there's a word for it and
so brain Specialists call that that is a
traumatic brain injury that is that is
so that's the same thing you do when you
have a stroke yep so part of his brain
shut off and his brain stem was keeping
him alive yep when that happens
to that degree your incidence of suicide
and uh like the statistically it's
heightened you know crazy yes now it can
also take 20 years to get better your
brain will heal itself it does oh yeah
but he got hit in the same place and the
NFL said it was his back he shook out
the cobwebs everybody knew that that was
the situation it's very surprising he
was put back in
we'll take the the brain doctor for
who's the independent brain uh
specialist concussion specialist yeah
Didn't Do the Right protocols and put
them back in the game right
he should have been back in the first
game first of all
and then the second game is Just insane
for him to play but you know you're
talking about high high stakes here
right yeah she definitely should have
been back early in the season right so
it's early but the the only thing is is
it is football I've seen this I don't
know how many times it's just what they
do but this one what makes it horrible
black guy for the NFL and just like the
UFC nothing's worse for the NFL or the
UFC than CT it's literally the one thing
that can bring them down not fighter pay
not you know a monopoly that's what all
whatever they can navigate through the
waters there CT they have no defense for
it's gonna hit them no I don't know when
it's going to do well the guy UFC with
the concussion movie all that stuff
super black guy right and so now they're
trying to figure out how to navigate
through that but the doctor allowed uh
two to play in that first game of the
concussion uh five he got fired didn't
do the normal Protocols of course but to
his no I don't say defense
this happens all the time just not to
this magnitude of this level where we
see it like this where two against his
head and he's throwing up gang signs and
now once everyone saw that yeah once
everyone saw him throw up West Side he
can't move right he's like this once
everyone sees that they go oh my God
yeah would you so it's gonna happen let
me ask you this and just carry on that
so when a guy when a fighter gets
knocked out right the the brain will
recovered to your point that you're
saying the brain will recover the
brain's crazy it gets better the problem
is with Fighters when they get knocked
down they go back in training like ah
but I'm not fighting but still getting
hit then the brain doesn't recover the
same yes so then the more like you get
knocked out as people say Cheney where
chin has nothing to do with it it's the
brain going we're in trouble shut down
let's shut down right so the texture
it's your brain protect yourself
so
um what I what I thought about was how
many how many parents whose kids are
about to play football who saw that go
you're not playing football you know you
wonder what it did to pop one in today's
world yeah probably a good amount good
amount right when I was kidding nothing
yeah you're aware of it yeah when you
see that you're like oh [ __ ] you know I
don't want that to be I didn't and my my
kid just started flag football and he'd
start tackling you know probably in a
year or two that yeah that's the
exception and it's also like what do you
think is gonna happen yeah yeah they're
hitting each other in the admit
don't put them out there no now we know
now we have enough information where
it's like oh if he gets a concussion
he's not playing next week no matter how
what he does but you know how it works
so in the NFL when you get drafted when
you come in you take a test
now the we did it in college too so
those tests where they're going to see
how concussed you are they're basic
questions but all the players know that
if you do get concuss if you don't pass
that test to a certain degree you're not
playing so they purposely make sure they
miss
questions on there so it's not that hard
oh wow
I think that and that's how bad the
football players want to play of course
yeah I mean there's so much money in the
line and you know I would play You're
Gonna Play You're gonna be like I'll
take the risk I'm not gonna get hit
again you grow up with it you know and
and to your point also like that is a
very rare thing to get hit in the same
spot again but it's just awful but um
UFC has to I think when you see I
re-watched that Justin gaichi uh Tony
Ferguson fight in there was a different
angle so I could hear it and I could see
something different and uh man that
fight that fight should have been
stopped right when he was like this you
know and same with uh Brian Ortega you
know so a lot of these things are you
know I think I think boxing stopped
earlier isn't it typically typically if
you're getting that out of class I'll
stop right not really I mean both of
them have their issues yeah the thing is
now it's like we're trying to and listen
I don't condone in this but it's just
part of the game it's like yeah they're
two professional cage fighters give me
some brains
what to what point would you say like if
somebody's getting that [ __ ] beat up
which one are you talking about like
let's say Ortega one or the 21st and one
at what point do you stop that fight
yeah I think because Fighters are too
tough right yeah the culture you gotta
learn to to fight another day but isn't
it that's on the graphic can't the ref
stop it they can okay and nobody that
they're they're in they're trying to
stop it yeah yeah no they have the power
to stop it but it's also like this
sisification of society where it's like
oh we don't want our football players
getting hurt we don't want our Fighters
getting concussed it's like what yeah
it's kind of man well so that you're
gonna have to stop filing but so here's
a question so in the 70s 80s even the
90s and early 2000s you were allowed to
hit the quarterback a lot harder than
you were allowed to today yep yeah and
those guys were fine not only that but
I'm saying so now that quarterbacks are
so protected
do you compare their stats with old old
player stats that is a factor well same
with Michael Jordan LeBron right LeBron
thing a completely different game yeah
because Jordan was getting beat up by
Detroit their game plan was to beat you
can't stop it make sure he doesn't
finish the game before he does he's
gonna be sore as [ __ ] right he's gonna
be walking different that was their game
LeBron never had LeBron never win a
single game going man it's gonna be a
rough one never the refs bail him out
yeah he's also I joined way bigger than
Jordan but still the the players are
bigger now yes everyone's big enough
I I don't even do to stop it until
people just finally go all right it's
just not worth the risk yeah but I keep
wondering about that because let's say
they're they're learning more and more
about CTE like information gets in you
and you go all right so your brain is
getting this that and the other thing
like I really wonder like how many
people are going to put their kids in
tackle football before the age of 16.
like in 10 years
or or are the stats going to be like
yeah people get the CT but a lot of
people are not affected by it you know
but B that's the majority of the the the
the stats is that right yes thinking
about all the people you know growing up
with to play football how many of them
actually have problems a lot of them are
thriving yes a lot of majority are yeah
so even the 90s and 80s and 70s when
they have all this research done the
majority of them are fine but the the
outliers the guys that have problems
they get highlighted well how about you
highlight all the guys that not
the majority of that announcers that you
hear speak yeah all plays football for
30 years yeah they're pretty good yes
Tony Romo got [ __ ] lit up yeah pretty
good pretty smart
CTE is real it clearly affects it it's
real but it's a lot of variables how
much did you get hit where'd you get hit
in the head how long did you play but
even with the variables I go with the
majority yeah like you I'm not gonna
base my sons or my kids life based off
the minority on anything yeah you don't
live a life like that and then if you're
so worried about uh CT and PTSD so
should we not send troops to war how far
you want to go those guys are way more
[ __ ] up there's way more people with
PTSD than CT yeah how or PTSD sucks
should we not go to war because you can
come back [ __ ] up
what do you want to do well no you just
let them I don't know if that's a that
that might not be an effective argument
the bottom line is it is though because
like the soldiers come back way more fun
football creates CTE to what extent we
don't know it's going to affect when you
have that kind of information it's going
to affect if people commit suicide
because of this like um what's his name
uh whoever yeah
um we go okay shot himself on the
Chester vehicle study his brain because
he knew something was wrong you're not
going to be that's real information that
has to be taken into an account okay
what do you do with it here's real
information more people commit suicide
off Instagram than playing football then
you want to shut down Instagram go ahead
try go ahead I do but no more people use
Instagram commit suicide than football
players not even close yeah yeah
yeah so what are we gonna do a lot of
people that commit suicide never played
football no yeah more people came with
suicide who didn't play football that's
interesting if football's not the
problem that's an interesting fact now
it ain't helping those guys that have
depression already well no I would say
you getting rid of football would be a
terrible idea oh my God I mean it'd be a
terrible idea the amount you get the
character you build the things you learn
but again you're gonna shut it down for
the minority like okay then shut down
the X Games as well yeah and shut down
scuba diving and shut down race car
driving I mean yeah dude if you go if
they start doing that Trend we're fine
we watch it because yeah it's very hard
to do and they're risking they're
risking their health yeah same with UFC
Mark Zuckerberg paid rented out entire
[ __ ] Arena just so he could watch UFC
that's hilarious you didn't know this I
did not know that he rented out an
entire he was like Caesar from Gladiator
he looked at Dana went like this I'm
like no we're not killing anybody
thumbs up or thumbs down it's crazy I
wish him to die please
Joshua I don't know why it's so
triggering to me drives me nuts what
that Mark Zuckerberg is also a fan and
was able to rent out the entire [ __ ]
Arena well no I think what it is is that
Mark Zuckerberg has the ability to race
you he can erase you he can get off
Facebook and and that now he wants the
ability to choke you unconscious as well
no he's not gonna have that ability he's
just not his DNA yeah he could train for
30 years yeah he's not he's not he's
probably not the most athletic no and
I'm never going to develop a Facebook
yeah he's not the most athletic guy he
doesn't look like it he's in defense
it's just crazy to me that he was able
to rent it out and we're all quiet wait
what did he run out the Apex Center
Mckenzie during fight this weekend wait
a minute wait a minute hold on he rented
out
for him his wife there's nobody in the
stands by it
what yeah
what he's Joffrey from Game of Thrones
no that's not true promise I don't
believe you no he rented it out
Mackenzie Jordan came out and was like
uh the look says even the headliner
McKenzie Jordan said during me a day I
know Mark Zuckerberg rent out the whole
event
yeah but he probably let everybody come
in nobody there was no one in the stands
very little or not nowhere no one in the
stands there's people around the outcome
but doing the stands like it was like
covert times like it was The Ultimate
Fight I don't believe that okay are you
telling me the truth yeah I don't know
this [ __ ] guy rented out
it says hot rumor no well because Dana
Karen goes it's absolutely not true and
then we watch it it's exactly true
no
no other people understand but nowhere
near the amount go to the go to the live
one chip okay but there's no fans in
attendance there's people that are UFC
Association
if you have the thing you'll see this
like that's there's no fans there's no
media they weren't allowed in
well that's that would that should drive
you nuts everybody wants to come see it
especially if you're like if you're so
he basically said Dana What's it gonna
cost for me to have this place to myself
that's what I said I don't know how it
goes down how who won that fight with
Mackenzie and MacKenzie's lasting
decision look see we get back empty go
ahead now around is zuckberg and the USC
officials but in the stands there's
nobody that's really quiet that's
obnoxious
all the seats
oh you dick
what a dick are you ready for this
you showed up late he only he missed the
entire prelims only showed up for the
main car oh that's what someone said I'm
not 100 sure but someone said that in
the on the article that crazy she looks
She's she's lost a lot of weight boys
she looks like she's see that place is
dead B see around you have though you if
you you UFC official stuff like that was
that crazy crazy right yeah I don't know
why it triggers me it should trigger you
I don't know why
anyway it's weird huh yeah whatever
that is like a Joffrey [ __ ] from Game of
Thrones I was to watch it alone please I
don't want to be bothered and give me
give me more tea and I want grapes I
heard he asked Dana when the Lions and
Tigers come out and Dana was like the
lions and tigers I want I want the
losers to be eaten
strange huh yeah very [ __ ] strong
like that's us saying on shops are like
you better Izzy better pray to God Mark
Zuckerberg don't become a fan your next
fight he rents out the [ __ ] Arena wow
nobody's there [ __ ] that how far are you
gonna let this guy go though I mean come
on grant that was a fight night at the
Apex a little different so so yeah
T-Mobile yeah still for the fighters I'd
be like wait what no problem dude if I'm
against Jordan I'm like well do I get a
percent of that since yeah what are you
doing that means my merch or whatever I
don't know how they do it these days so
I make no money off any of that stuff
yeah and this guy who's worth how much
billions of dollars you can just rent it
out it's nuts yeah that's Robert Barron
[ __ ] it's super robber band I mean
privileged it's just not good nuts yeah
it's very Joffrey Game of Thrones
all right I'll get a shark on the phone
I want to call Zuckerberg hey Mark they
call me if he was here I'd be like it's
so great to have you here man you're
amazing
all right so the first one is just I
don't know what I did oh before you
start this it'd be real quick dude
um would you think of so everyone I meet
like liver King real deal is he the real
deal I'm like yeah he's a good guy
yes I was never like the biggest fan
like doing wrong I like the guy and I
like where he represents but I don't
follow everything he does so when they
say he's coming I was like all right
cool
uh in my head I'm like I want it's like
an act I wonder if he's just doing this
isn't off camera he's like listen dude
no here's my attention here's my take on
the legit guy like I had a I thought he
was a good dude well here's my take on
the liver King he's a lot of fun what
what is there to hate are you hating on
him because you're you're you don't like
to eat sliver that you think he does
steroids I don't care about any of that
no he's just a character who is fun he
wears this beard he's got all those
people around him he's clearly a great
family man he's clearly all about his
family and he makes hundreds of millions
of dollars so so what I'm looking at is
a uh uh like all my it's a character
it's a cartoon character he's he'll tell
you it's a character does he sleep on
wood all the time probably not he
probably stays it he told here he said I
stay at five star resorts that that's a
character it's it's a great American
story he's like let me see how I can
make a name for myself and all the noise
I'm gonna get super muscular injacked
I'm gonna never wear clothes and I'm
going to eat raw meat and all of us are
like this is [ __ ] hilarious but um
I can't believe you didn't ask him if
he's downstairs shut up I was like I
don't care I don't care if he's I don't
give a [ __ ] I assume everybody's on
steroids I literally that has nothing to
do with this story also I think what
people are mad is that they there's that
he doesn't that he alludes to being all
natural yeah and and being sub Primal
being Primal is probably not somebody
who would use Peds but again I don't
care but also we've had Mr Olympia on
here yeah you want us to ask Mr Olympia
yeah
so with Phil Heath is a good example
Philly Heath who achieved major
Excellence like was a total outlier in
his field that I'm interested in his
mindset yeah I mean his success mindset
right do you understand what I'm saying
but I mean but follow me on this so
there's a baseball player who has
crushed all the records he may have
played five more years or even 10 more
here is because he took Peds but it
still doesn't mean that he won a Golden
Glove and hit all those balls I I'm sure
it helped but at the same time it
doesn't take away from that work ethic
or that Insanity Roger Clemens that's a
debate going on right now so Aaron uh
judge you don't fall baseball I didn't
judge the Yankee he's at 61. yeah he
tied Roger Marissa's record in American
League and then if he hit 62 a lot of
people go that's the record
a baseball historians go well no the
record is whatever 73 by Barry Bonds and
then people go well it's not because it
is steroids but then you go well hold on
if you guys are going to do that then
you have to do it across the board
because there's pitchers and other
baseball players during that time period
of the steroid timers the pictures are
on [ __ ] of course so the guy throwing
the balls on [ __ ] the guy who's hitting
the balls on [ __ ] but you're only
allowing the guy who was throwing the
ball to be on the Hall of Fame right
that doesn't make sense no at the time
they were all on it was a steroid area
everybody was on it right the Adderall
all sorts of [ __ ] yes correct so you
can't just say well that guy was doing
it it's okay if these guys do so the
record is 73. yeah it's not 62. but also
Aaron judge is a very big man he's also
insanely athletic so what are you doing
are you saying that Aaron judge has
achieved Excellence after all this time
because of steroids see I I look it up
I'm sorry no one's saying about Aaron
judge no no I'm saying I'm saying you
and I you and I can that we talk about
this all the time like look man
being really good at something and
sustaining it like it never gets easy
like being so stand up look man I'm not
to say what you will I I'm pretty good
at standing man and I've been pretty
good for a long [ __ ] time it's never
been easy and the reason I got really
good is because I obsessed over it and
wrote now I have to write another hour
it's no easier I promise it's no easier
but the argument with Aaron judge on why
his is more impressive this should be
the argument not steroids if you look at
the the pictures when Barry Bonds and
Mark McGuire were hitting their home
runs which the MLB knew what was going
on made all this money and did all this
marketing sure and then once it got to
some point like oh yeah those are bad
boys but they reaped all the benefits
which is out of control
but that please stop coughing but the
thing is is uh Barry Bonds would only
face like in a game maybe two or three
different pitchers he would never face
the pitcher the same picture numerous
times Aaron judge in a single game
because the game's changed he's facing
so many different pictures pitchers who
are all much better than the pictures
back then so he's facing a variety of
different pictures still hitting 61 home
runs yeah the game has changed that's
not Aaron judge or Barry Bond's fault
just the game's changed with pitchers so
he what his level of difficulty is way
harder but I'm saying it's very
difficult now anything like that is very
difficult like people used to hate on
Floyd Mayweather I was like do you you
know what a genius he is do you know how
hard that guy works like I don't what
are you doing because they don't want to
believe in like those people are
different than them no I want to go well
even even with the even with the [ __ ]
liver King oh the only reason is that
because on steroids do me a favor y'all
who's less than this you want to hate on
liver king take whatever you think he's
on eat liver take your shirt off and put
quality content online let me know if
you make millions of dollars no hundreds
and hundreds of dollars I don't have
hundreds of millions that's a lot of
money not hundreds of millions
aggressive I see his YouTube numbers no
not from that from his businesses from
the supplement yeah yeah he doesn't make
money I'm talking about from his
businesses I don't know you know he's a
very colorful
I I got nothing but positive energy from
that [ __ ] guy he cracked me up yeah I
thought it was like just a you know all
I do is meet people myself he's the same
my camera and off my superpowers to read
people call [ __ ] yes good guy yeah
really good person I was gonna say
earlier you want me to ask him this
thing and get the same exact response
that 40 other people have gotten it's
pointless yeah
he's gonna break the news did you notice
how he was the same guy when the cameras
were 100 I was really impressed he's
just uh he's a and he's super
enthusiastic he obviously loves his life
loves his [ __ ] out of his wife yeah
I love a guy like that how he thanked
you guys how he's like let me take a
minute not just go thank you for having
me on thinking about to me that was a
sign of a really like emotionally mature
individual
am I going to use liver no absolutely I
almost threw up I'm almost [ __ ] my pants
I couldn't but God bless him but also
his message is pretty positive you know
his message is basically take care of
yourself yeah like and by the way it's
not that expensive you can do this this
and yeah it's expensive but yeah I hear
you you know like his message was great
and if that helps people who gives off
yeah but he's kind of like look you can
eat eggs you know what I mean it's like
hey eat 30 eggs today yeah it's not that
expensive well he also said when I'm in
Rome I'll I'll do what the Romans did he
had whiskey he'll eat fruit
food like if he's there
he's cute with us yes yeah yeah I like
that he's not he like he's both stating
these strong principles but going and
yeah sometimes I can't always pull it
off or I'm not always I'm not dogmatic
the reason I liked him is he has a sense
of humor about himself that's what I
liked about him he's got a sense of
humor about himself yeah I really
enjoyed him yeah all right Jim what do
you got um
maybe let's take a little break because
I know this hits close to home you're
losing your hair dude yeah dude now
listen don't don't feel bad bro I don't
know don't feel bad because two out of
three Bros will experience some form of
hair loss by the time the 35 you hear
that Jay 50 million dudes dude 50
million men in the U.S suffer from male
pattern baldness that's why our friends
at keeps offers a simple affordable way
and stress-free way to keep your hair
all right all you do conveniently meet
with a virtual doctor all right and then
it's at your door and they deliver
straight to your door every three months
so you never have to leave your crib 24
7 care and support they got your back
low cost take it from a guy who spent
like does it three million dollars
millions cost me a million I don't mean
to flex but Brian Tara's got some
treatment started as low as ten dollars
per month and keeps offers generic
versions of the two FDA approved
medications to prevent hair loss one of
them being finasteride now listen
remember prevention is key treatments
can take four to six months the results
so after now before your hair is
completely gone if you're you're ready
to take action prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com fighter to receive your first
month free of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash fighter get your
first month free keeps.com finder keep
your hair first one is just going back
to a previous episode where Brian said
that Aaron
Rodgers had a quote or something like
that at a press conference oh that was
CM Punk yeah so we got tagged a bunch
Mark sent it to me as well yeah so we'll
just play it real quick show this watch
this I'm a little [ __ ] sniffy just
fine I'm old and I'm [ __ ] tired I
work with [ __ ] children
but he wouldn't say I work with actual
children he's saying these guys are
babies yeah yeah and I thought that was
awesome
I didn't realize there's a different
angle where he says that and I work with
bucket children yeah he's saying these
kids these guys are babies yeah that's
Diane Rogers though right well no close
wait show the other end
you can see it kind of looks like no no
not from that angle show the other angle
and you'll see there's another one
there's another angle especially if
Aaron Rodgers said and I worked with
[ __ ] children that's why I was
referring to the Green Bay Packers I
would know but in my mind maybe this is
for you
same here
I'm saying yeah
but it says all lead wrestling behind
him though yeah not the Green Bay
Packers all right there you go I thought
he was saying like leave me alone I work
with kids that's why Brian may sound
okay yeah that's the problem with sound
bites yeah you probably hear him Rogers
saying he's [ __ ] he doesn't feel like
doing this he has to work with [ __ ]
children I'm like oh my God this is
awful no CM Punk'd be like hey I'm done
with the match cold and tired nice guy
though right great guy yeah phenomenal
guy really really good guy
all right the next one
um a little bit controversial this guy
Caleb McLaughlin who's in a stranger
things he made a statement recently I
think he's overseas somewhere and he he
says that he's the least liked person on
the show Because he believes this racism
has some has something to do with it
he's leaning into it he even said he
even said like uh when they go do like
you know events yeah which I don't yeah
[ __ ] because you're not 11. because
you're not the redhead girl the star of
the shows he's also a young kid that
would be like Carlton on Fresh Prince to
be like this is racism just because
Will's Cooling in to rap his lines
longer than mine no no the show's called
The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air [ __ ] you
know yeah so with him saying this is
like all right dude you're leaning into
this the show is designed for 11 to be
the star of the show yeah the show is
designed for that redhead girl or the
the guy who plays uh vetna to be the
star of the show you weren't casted as
the star so when you go on these [ __ ]
trips and the line's not as long this
was by Design it's not racist to
something at all how many times I've
been on [ __ ] those things when I'm
doing a TV show and nobody shows up for
me because somebody else is way more
yeah do a show with Jessica Simpson at
the height of her Fame tell me how that
goes like what are you talking about
like it's just that's a bad thing to
lean into I think and he has 15.4
million followers oh my gosh Jesus
Christ well he says here so so uh he's
conducive the discrepancy in the cast
social media stats his own Instagram has
15.4 million followers Crimea River and
Browns who's the star of the show has
58.5 million uh Noah snaps has 27.6
million and you're like why am I the
least favorite young kid
he's also a young kid I'm on the same
show as everyone sees one but you're not
the star and you also weren't even close
with my favorite characters he observed
credit and his mother and father with
being awesome and my parents had to be
like it's a sad truth it's because
you're the black child on the show not
true yeah I don't agree with that
otherwise uh people wouldn't like they'd
like LeBron James wouldn't have the kind
of I just don't buy it and also um like
you said I don't watch the show but he's
not featured prominently I mean he he's
one of the main kids but it's like he's
you know if he died in the first episode
I'm like oh man he was great and I don't
give a [ __ ] yeah now if 11 died of the
redhead that'd be Fury yeah
yes
all right yeah Brian this is for you
your favorite porn star
he's gonna have like a multi-episode
series on Netflix about his life but
apparently it's not about it's not
identical to his life but it's about
about his life is this a it's a
dramatization so this is what he says
he's my hero by the way he's a beautiful
story inspired by my life but not my but
not my it's not my favorite porn star
the women in history when he was younger
were the most beautiful top five come on
hey Brian you brought him up and says
your favorite and don't be less gay now
just oh you know what I know what's
going on there that's why he didn't go
that new uh the new movie with the gay
guys the Bridesmaids with gays that's
the next story
so right now you didn't go to Bros
because you were worried people seeing
them I don't know what you're talking
about I don't know anything about that
so Bros is a Billy Eichner he used to be
the man on the street guy uh that's
funny yeah he's really funny but he's
saying that potentially that the reason
why it was a box office fail is because
it's a gay movie that's no it's because
guys like me are not gonna go because I
can't identify with it I also I also
didn't go to Crazy Rich Asians yeah I'm
not a crazy rich Asian what's what's a
bigger demographic gay guys are women
huh like like bridesmaid I also went to
see bridesmaid yeah 50 of the population
going yeah no but hold on Brian that
Crush because the there's a large
majority of Asians in America there's
not a large majority of gays in America
so they thought America would like yes
finally
but the normal Brew I'm not taking my
I'm not taking my date to that is it
good maybe the movie sucks no the
movie's supposed to be really good I
just have no desire to see it better
watch it I'll watch it if it's really
good but I don't for me if it's if it's
not something I would go to so you go
it's about a bunch of gay guys I just
I'm not I I there are other things I'm
interested in that's all it doesn't it
it's it's not even a thing I'm just like
I don't I don't care I'm a little listen
I hope that I I wish the movie success I
don't I don't care
yeah I don't care if it's a good movie I
don't care young dudes aren't going to
that bro young young guys aren't going
to they've got young guys who are
straight and that's the vast majority of
moviegoers I'm I'm sorry I'm not going
to that movie yeah gay men will go to
the mid-americas
not go in that movie Middle America like
the blue collar guys who make up the
majority of the money nobody's going
they're not going to that no so I when I
saw this I was curious like was there
any gay movies that were big so then I
remember going back mountain right
brokeback mountains actually did really
well that was big in Hollywood I don't
think Brokeback Mountain made that much
money than that all right yeah it was
the highest grossing release for that
particular 178 million production right
now I'm just going to say the well uh
critics scores are like in the 90s I'm
looking at the audience reviews and
although it said the audience reviews
are high I'm looking at individual
reviews I was really hyped to see this
movie and then really disappointed by it
the most grotesque movie I've seen
absolute dog [ __ ] the movie flopped to
the box I was get read the reviews here
something isn't right hey Mark here's
the thing yeah when the so when
everything so you remember when
Hollywood was like got accused of racism
or like oh [ __ ] and they swing all the
way over yeah and then all of a sudden
the Oscars are just black people yeah
this is Hollywood being like look we
gave gays a movie yeah and then the
report knowing those critics would dare
also critics are so outdated it's like
lady king or the the woman King the
movie
[ __ ] of course but they did it because
they got crazy reviews
yes it depends those things align but
sometimes they don't but right it's very
rare they're aligned but the thing is is
you don't want to base a review off of
uh one person who writes for the
Washington Post no YouTube
you're like Shawshank Redemption right
there's some saying sometimes everyone's
in agreement but you're right when
there's something here what is well this
we get smart this this we could smell
that it's gonna get raving reviews and
that guy oh America's just not rapist no
we're ready okay number five it was a
good one Grace crushed it sure well and
Grace was a [ __ ] monster how many
truly incredible movies truly incredible
don't make any money a lot yeah I mean
but like truly incredible yeah truly
incredible oh oh I see what you're
saying yeah like where it's like it's
not just like it was pretty good you're
like that was the biggest I've seen
people find a year or three years or
five years people find that that's right
that's hard and Brokeback Mountain was a
great movie great [ __ ] drama
heartbreaking movie and Brendan asked me
this weekend would you have played one
of the roles and I said yeah I'll get up
me too yeah 100 Brandon said no that's
super cool I'm not doing it
when I played gay we played I was a gay
Indian yep and I was a gay uh you've
been got a little backlash for that did
we yeah
I remember that now we get completely
cancel
um yeah but with this stuff like you can
tell Hollywood has an agenda to push it
when there's a thing and I don't know
when Hollywood politicians when you
force Americans to do something it is in
our DNA to fight back Brennan wait till
November
yeah oh yeah I know it's in our DNA to
fight back and if you're not
you know somebody said something
interesting because
woke and young because there's this
movement to the left that that is you
know really Progressive the new Punk
Rockers are going to be the right wing
it's always that way it's like kids will
start to push back on their parents yeah
you know you're raising me to be
anti-race and all that it's like I don't
[ __ ] I just want to live my life that
guy that I brought up earlier will
Franken in 2016 he was like Trump is
punk rock yeah and that was oh yeah dude
like if you were true like you're very
true if you were a red Maga you're like
holy sh that guy is punk rock edgy he's
edgy are you watching a star where you
see a maggot how you're like holy [ __ ]
dude oh man you might as well
oh my God you're gangster but correct
when you're when you're in places like
Tacoma first pecan you see a whole bunch
of trump t-shirts you see a whole bunch
of trump like you see a lot of that a
lot of America is what is the last time
you saw Biden Shirt By the way I don't
think I've ever seen it I don't think I
can see the go I just see the go Brandon
Church no no I see I see Biden stickers
no I know I'm just saying that as far as
merch
bumper stickers the only place you'll
see a bumper sticker for Biden is on a
Subaru or on a Prius that's it you don't
see them anywhere it's a lesbian with a
mass driving by herself with a
convertible that makes no sense yeah
it's usually it's usually somebody who's
it's so ridiculous yeah Biden's merch
sucks though he needs help with his
merch game yeah Trump's merch is lit I
don't I don't like it but I'm just
saying nothing went viral the hats and
[ __ ] oh yeah it was nuts how many of you
seen thousands of the hats you know like
I just I've never seen a single person
wearing something that says well then
then I have that red Supreme hat is one
of my favorite hats I have to stop
wearing it be like oh approach I'm like
no it's just a red hat yeah he can't
have Red Hats yeah I can't wear red hat
anymore no yeah you don't want that heat
well like I have a lot of cops coming my
shows and they gave me this cool uh
Boston PD hoodie and I was winning
around like Newberry Street and all over
the Fenway the looks I got from people
and I was like Wow Come on even with
just a police officer police hoodie all
day oh I rocked it all day [ __ ] I'll
wear that [ __ ] all day yeah
I love cops
all right job check this out this uh
woman up from Montana she got a wolf tag
right to shoot a wolf I sent you and
Rogan
she was super proud of him
posted it and thought it was a wolf you
[ __ ] idiot hey here's the thing
Huskies look like wolves do you see a
real wolf it's like having a [ __ ]
Chrysler 300 and a real Rolls-Royce
Phantom balls up you're like oh they
don't look like each other
put a [ __ ] husky next to a real
[ __ ] wolf what the she thought it was
a pup she thought it was a pup and
there's no way I there's no I don't
think I would ever and even the smallest
amount mistaken a husky for a wolf yeah
well the thing is if you're one of the
woods and that you just see that running
by I can see but she posted it she's
super proud she's holding it up and I'm
like that's [ __ ] that's a dog it's so
obviously kill the Siberian Husky hey B
she shot it and then skinned it oh yeah
that's the horrible part so I'll show
you I'm not gonna show the pictures on
there but I mean I love dogs but look at
that she's like look cut myself that
right there is just got myself a wall
oh no uh I you know what I gotta be
honest I feel bad for this woman
she's a
I don't know it was in the first place
though well so we'll wolf tags are
because they end up eating livestock and
if you don't kill them they're gonna
[ __ ] get hunted anyway
that's a husky she was like oh where was
that why was this husky in the woods
yeah also yeah like imagine you're like
what Hey where's my husky they said that
someone got rid of like six Huskies or
whatever
who gets rid of huskies
shed a lot so if you were black all the
time I understand let them out the door
uh to all a lot of things in our
explosive tattoo whatsoever I purchased
my wolf tag prior to leaving for a bear
hunt in the event I ran into a wolf in
which I came to encounter with what I
thought could be a hybrid during this
time my safety was top priority this
animal is growling howling [ __ ] and
coming at me like he's gonna eat me yes
I made a mistake
honest mistake honestly I would still
have shot because it was aggressive
coming directly for me so please remove
all your posting I just shot and killed
someone's pet I'm a human did I make
mistake think it was a hybrid wolf pup
however there are no charges are against
me as I did not break any laws I'm not a
cruel individual just putting just put
killing people I'm not a cruel
individual just put killing people
just out killing but by the way so once
she killed this animal and she had has
it right in front of it you howdy how
could you mistaken that after a while
because she's in the after she killed
him she probably hasn't posed but she
probably hasn't seen one so to her it's
like yeah that's a [ __ ] and you don't
expect a husky in the middle of nowhere
to come running at you but these
somebody dropped off all these dogs in
the woods
and wolf territory
uh I would never well personally I
couldn't kill a wolf I love Wolf the
fact that she was so proud bear hunting
she wasn't looking for a while she was
looking but she got the wolf tag because
they said they were going to be around
there but then also Turtle not Turtle
defend they can't kill dogs but but the
Husky it would be tough like what's the
chance like when are you gonna run the
husky in the woods in the wild and then
I don't I think she's just trying to
save her ass they're going it was
snarling and growling I mean coming at
me I would have shot anyway that
probably never happens she's trying to
say face here
Huskies were abandoned but sale she
thought it was a wolf like pup or like a
hybrid yeah kind of see that no I
believe that she does because she was so
proud and posing with it if she realized
she'd kill the Husky she's probably like
oh I gotta get out of here you know I
would yeah so she probably really
believed it was but I'm like you should
know better yo we'll give it away the
dog collar said Sammy on it
God damn it lady here's another
Wilderness Outdoors one so there's a
walleye fishing contest and uh Steven
Ronaldo reposted this too and one of the
there's two guys that are that I guess
placed before so they found out that
they're stuffing weights inside the
stomachs of the walleye while they're
alive
um I I don't know I don't know if they
have to keep them alive or not and also
fish fillets in there as well so I'll
just play the video real quick
seven nine zero we did Big Fish seven
nine zero and Kevin Mowry coming up the
scales I bet you this in the first time
they've done yeah
let's watch this
this video kind of sucks
oh damn look I guess I get the [ __ ] out
of here
oh those those boys are mad yeah that's
that that's that storm the capital
energy those boys what's that story that
guy said capital and I gotta goes get
the [ __ ] out of here wow how dear
[ __ ] dummy this is a better video
from Stephen Noah
[Music]
don't say you're going to jail I don't
think he's going to jail buddy
I watch they start slicing it open God
did he get out of there alive look how
mad the guys in the back dude some guy's
going why did you do this
all of them everything people are gonna
cheat
I like the guy filming
[ __ ]
so he's slicing the belly open
look at that Jesus
I found fish fillets and weights inside
of it
I like Diego you're going to jail well
no no he's not but also um enjoy your
life
even fishing is corrupt I quit
uh here's a quick one because he's a
friend of the show they were probably
making bank winning other competitions
yeah they're making money and someone's
like how the [ __ ] are their fish so
heavy all the time wow and then finally
something dumbass and also what a dick I
like the guy filming you're going to
jail I like that uh and he goes get the
[ __ ] out of thousands of dollars
oh damn 10 tens of thousand did he get
out of there alive or did they skin him
like that husky but he's a piece of [ __ ]
so did they skin him like the Husky
no that's Hey listen I'm just saying I
understand preacher Lawson I guess he
did a kickboxing match recently so
preacher asked me a while ago give him
an MMA fight
um but you know he's a badass
I mean he's athletic huh it's [ __ ]
previously I'm deleting these if I lose
yeah and then afterwards
damn
how's his uh have we seen him I didn't
see the actual fight is there any
footage of him and preacher is [ __ ]
hilarious he's funny he's so funny he's
funny good friends Josh going to prison
with his butt he has a big bubble butt
so [ __ ] funny
isn't it you see this
handsome [ __ ]
he's giving his dates too awesome oh wow
this did that like
uh this is more I think this is
head movement so this is last year
students
and there's no uh video of his recent
fight he has to react into my second
fight there's no third fight on there
it should be the nurse thing right you
know
you can't uh find a kid time I wanted to
do it
no I don't see it
he's so [ __ ] funny though it's great
good for him man yeah
he's so funny hey I'm about to show
y'all another one of my good friend let
me try one more thing
yeah I'd love to see the fight
because January 80 had one she was there
generates oh MMA not just kickboxing I'm
gonna see that one
what he did a straight up MMA fight
let's go now it's a real fight
s is crazy [ __ ] yeah he is
it's damaged because they have shin
guards on but you can tell huh okay
yeah [ __ ] look at the creature movement
not bad at all not at all oh [ __ ]
punches oh
his jab was nice
oh wow he's [ __ ] this kid up
[Applause]
oh
can you damage
oh whoa
it's 18 minutes and let's see if he is
the decision
ah man 55 70.
by 70.
Jesus
well that's the fight it's a real fight
[Applause]
preachers out there man [ __ ]
impressive
oh [ __ ] you lost this one interesting he
was lighting him up in the beginning
good for him
[Applause]
good for Preacher Man that's badass [ __ ]
yeah it's badass putting your money away
let's get you all right Mark's here
let's see here okay
uh let's go with the groom fail huh yeah
that's a fun one
so groom suffers horrific injury trying
to show bride how much he loves her oh
no
he doesn't do it I love him see that
that's pretty much it right there oh
he's just him slipping they're like
doing like a little dance and then you
see what happened to his arm there
you see your elbow's not supposed to
bend that way oh did he break his arm
yeah so he's got this choreographed
thing he's running around and it's just
a little slow oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and then I just spend the night and then
I just um
[ __ ] bro
he tried man oh look at him he's out
well my friend got married and and the
best his father's best her father's best
friend
had a heart attack and died right on the
dance floor it's a bad side that's the
divorce huh the divorce they lasted a
long time but they lasted a long time
but God damn yeah
I know those dance floors hey take that
thing off your face why is he got why
has he got oxygen on his face
put him out yeah he probably had surgery
oh man this tit out like that too on
your wedding night oh that's a bad tip
this lady's like God damn it's got a
little kind of going on I'm depressed
don't show me that stuff it makes me sad
yeah what about the um
Antonio Brown on the subject of Antonio
Brown
there's trolling Tom Brady he posted a
picture of him and Gisele kind of funny
huh
I guess Antonio capped off what's been a
wild weekend with a curious Instagram
move one day after a video service
between battle with wide receiver
exposing himself to guests into May 14th
pool incident in Dubai Brown took the
Instagram on Sunday to share a photo of
himself with supermodel Gisele Bundchen
we lived with Tom Brady right when he
first came to Florida Tom had him live
with him to keep him on track that's
right and then he says in the caption
put that [ __ ] on
hmm
I don't know didn't they like each other
though yeah Tom Brady vouchers where
does that put that [ __ ] on though what
does that mean I don't know
anything put that [ __ ] on like the the
Super Bowl winning shirt or something
like a commenter said huh disrespectful
that man lets you in his crib yeah he
said like Tom let him live together
that's [ __ ] up what else you got
what you like
um let's do the uh my great uncle Walt
Disney
was she on uh Marin
I was listening to her on Marin
I don't know if it's specified oh yeah
exactly exactly uh Disney airs Abigail
Disney ripped her great uncle Walt
Disney for being fascist and smoking
anti-semitism
but isn't that because that's that's the
market decided right but the market has
also
decided that there has to be this these
huge rewards for shareholders huge
rewards for management we're not there's
so much cash flow she's going against
Disney they're so so profitable and
we're not using that cash to reward
workers why should they live at the very
bottom of what is tolerable or
acceptable
that was more that was sort of a
different point than the article
um the the other quotes that I thought
were interesting were he boarded on
rabid fascism
um and just tell us about some of the
decisions he made this has been going on
for a long time yeah they weren't sure
about delving into the stereotypes that
served them uh the three little pigs in
the big bad wolf uh he portrayed the
wolf as a Jewish Peddler and named one
of the wisecracking black crows from
Dumbo Jim Crow yep
look people were racist back then yeah
unabashedly so it sucked being black
to say the least and so I guess your
message now as we heard from that clip
is more worker friendly like she said
they were men of their time that's an
excuse they knew
I don't know if they did
my grandfather wasn't racist
and he was old
just depends on who you were as a person
man yeah they got rid of that uh uh the
Splash Mountain Song Song of the South
apparently I don't know when I went to
the South I noticed how many uh families
I was friends with their kids I couldn't
believe how how the n-word was used all
the time and you use that word in my
house and my grandmother's house my
grandfather's house my mother's house my
father's house I would have gotten I
would have gotten the [ __ ] kicked out of
me when was this I was born in 1967. so
you're saying it as a kid as a kid when
I grew up the n-word was used among
white people in America in the South and
in the North By the way when I went to
summer camp the kids that I knew who
were from New York in New York if you
were Irish or if you were Italian in New
York City or you grew up in in the
boroughs of the Bronx or Brooklyn you
used the n-word all the time
you use the n-word all the [ __ ] time
and I heard it all the time there is no
doubt that racism was alive and well in
the North and the South and we've made
big strides but did you see the guy who
he's selling solar panels we're doing
Kingston solar panels it just messes up
and he brings you guys doorbell
guys Black Angus Hey sir he goes I'm
just going around the neighborhood we
sell uh solar panels too and he said the
n-word
and he goes oh no I didn't mean that not
and the guy was [ __ ] off close the door
it's the worst this is the greatest it's
the worst hiccup of all time why would
he say that no I don't know I didn't
slip but clearly it's a guy who's
accustomed to saying the n word let's
just put it that way
they're probably like it's all over chin
I don't know if YouTube's gonna do it
it's it's the worst slip of all time and
he just stays there at the door like oh
my God I [ __ ] up is that is that a
white guy yeah get ready for this piece
it's the worst app all time oh hey how
you doing okay
now we're in 1845. okay so we do solar
around here we're just coming around
so instead of neighbor you know what he
said talk about the neighbors
neighborhood but he said N word Hood I
think he said it's literally it's
everywhere
he's also Latina Latino and and I'm just
so mortified when you hear the real
thing you're like holy that's exactly so
what happens is among your group you're
talking about that uh maybe do it on uh
Twitter how embarrassing oh it's the
biggest [ __ ] of all time I don't I don't
know what happened to him I don't know
if he lost his job or what well it's
just a major disaster
oh dude he it's and he started he stops
at the end and he's just like
damn
oh man
so how would you search on Twitter
you can't search for the sales menu I'm
already cringing oh no way worse it's
way worse oh no
here it is
so the guy's at the door right now you
guys now we're in 1845. okay so we do
solar around here we're just coming
around talking years
sorry dude neighbors I apologize
oh God
damn it I can't take it oh no keep my
answering because he goes he thinks he's
like man maybe I can salvage this lunch
and he's not Latino Brian he's white
his name is Fernando
look at him he's like God he realized he
[ __ ] up he's like God maybe I should
go back
okay
again he's thinking about going back
this is It's rewinding to the front oh
that's so [ __ ] embarrassing
in your mind you're thinking to yourself
how crazy would it be if I said that
like you can say you can like there are
times when you can think like as a human
being you go can you imagine if I said
something like that like we all do that
I've never done that no I'm saying I've
never done I've never had been like oh
don't say the n-word here no but you can
in your mind you can be like can you
imagine if I went up and said something
like you can you can always think of the
worst case scenario because you're doing
this job and you have time I didn't give
him too much credit I think you used the
word and just came out it's too natural
I don't know and it wasn't like N I G G
oh I know it was awesome that was
so painful
okay I did a slip before but now like
that but so you know I was hanging out
my friends and there's two there's a gay
couple and it was always in my mind that
there's a gay couple don't say anything
stupid and of course suddenly I'm like
to talk to my other friend oh that's
that's that shirt is so gay or something
like that I'm like oh and I never say
that but for whatever reason I was
thinking gay so it came out sometimes
yeah I had a buddy I was growing up with
his dad passed away from cancer when he
was like two so he grew up with a dad
and he's like his dad was his hero we're
playing a game and I was beating this
beating the [ __ ] out of him and I he was
like starting to get all mad and like he
was talking [ __ ] to me and I was like
why don't you come get your dad down
there and beat his ass and he was all
and I was like oh I'm so he's like [ __ ]
you like oh my God I'm I was like 12 and
I was like oh no I didn't mean you're
dead did I ever tell you I'm
so my buddy is my buddy Gavin is is
cutting he's cutting
um Warrior the movie
and
the editor's there and he's just editing
and so I'm with Gavin I'm with my other
buddy and I'm with my other buddy and so
uh Gavin said something like
um I got this like pain you know or
something like that [ __ ] oh got this
you know thing or this is bugging me and
I go cancer you have cancer
like right behind the wedding
both his parents had terminal cancer
you just didn't know and the guy the guy
on the thing was just doing this he
didn't move I was like he's like he's
probably like I'll see you guys later
he's a professional right there yeah but
he probably knows too he's like he's
done but I do that like like my buddy
Kevin has he had a shirt off and there
was a sit on his back and I and I walked
by and I go that's cancer you don't have
a lot you don't have long to live and I
just kept walking like you know yeah but
sometimes yeah so if you joke around
maybe cancer isn't too much maybe yeah
but I like joking about him no I just
you gotta
about cancer
Megan Kelly says put your vag away or
Putin's Newt Convoy or the Green Goblins
Biden thinks Coast Guard remember them
fires did you see did you see [ __ ]
did you see [ __ ] Hillary Clinton
having a serious conversation with Megan
the stallion her and Chelsea about whop
or WAP that that great song that was so
empowering it's just them trying to wet
ass [ __ ] that's just them trying to get
a fan base wow look we're hip we're cool
how about that [ __ ] song for us Chelsea
get out of here
which one which one
let's see the Green Goblins I thought
this was pretty interesting
so at first I thought like maybe is this
some sort of like Tick Tock prank video
trained victims mom slams complete
animals and bizarre neon leotards who
assaulted robbed NYC teens damn they're
the Green Goblin gang and the Furious
mom of one of their victims says the
fiends were complete animals randomly
attacking their daughter on her birthday
of all days and they're it's females and
just attacking the slave for what reason
I guess it was a robbery newly released
video uh captured the bizarre group of
female oh they had two guns wearing full
body and young green leotards as they
punched and tossed around two 19 year
old women on a green man or a Subway wow
train uh about 2 a.m Sunday the victims
were robbed of a cell phone and a
handbag that's a lot of work to just rob
a cell phone in a handbag huh well it's
also pretty easy to find them they're
singing and you're the green guy green
the guys in Manhattan Beach
guns 11 guys with guns came in the mid
like came in at like 6 00 p.m in on
Manhattan Beach robbed that jewelry
still got away with a million dollars
worth of shoes one million dollars never
got caught got in their car a gang and I
talked to the guy was there yeah he came
in with their guns and just took out
took literally a million dollars and the
cops are the cops are like yeah they
kind of wanna and also you don't really
you know you take a big loss insurance
doesn't pay for all that no well I was
watching I don't know why people are
fascinated by but maybe I do because I
watch it whenever there's a car like
like a car chase you know the news will
stop whatever breaking news car chase
down the 101. let's watch it the other
night you know now the rule in
California is they won't pursue or chase
the person so they'll put the spikes out
but they don't want to injure people the
cops will just back off and they'll and
then even the news reporters like you
know for those of you that don't know
the chopper follows them but they're not
the cops don't pursue it because they
don't want them because more people get
hurt with them trying these crazy
Maneuvers so just let them go now
it's like just so you know that the the
you know the cops are gonna live to
fight another day though hopefully he
messes up again they find him like oh
wow wow that's pretty ballsy yeah the
guy was [ __ ] chucking driving like
Fast and Furious though backwards and
[ __ ] in a Civic damn
scary
alrighty let's do one more which one
what do you think about the uh Putin's
new Convoy because I think this is a
or do you want to have fun I'm scared of
it I'm scared of it well you know they
have different rules of engagement in
Russia
they believe in using tactical nukes for
example to clear out a field so that
troops can March through it even though
the guys who March through that are
gonna die of radioactive poisoning
pretty soon right so they just have a
different attitude towards nukes and it
is not unfeasible that they might use
that a lot of this is uh you know
stereotactic yeah
but they I'm just saying they do have
different like they their philosophy
yeah using nukes is different yeah
in Warfare and then also NATO because
they're saying right Ukraine wants to
meet with NATO to sign with them but
NATO's not going to do it because if we
do that then it's on that we need they
we need a uh he needs a face saving way
to get the [ __ ] out of Ukraine that's
really yes yeah look at that he's got a
very human face doesn't he Jesus
yeah so a military train that belongs to
the forces responsible for Russia's
nuclear Arsenal has been spotted moving
toward the front lines in Ukraine my
thing let's say he went crazy he just
went batshit crazy and started launching
nukes they're saying that he can't
really [ __ ] with America too much no
like someone New York he might be able
to reach but not much well no no it's
also that you know the truth is NATO has
the capability to destroy uh Russia's
entire Army in a long weekend it's the
problem is that if you give the
ukrainians weapons that are too
devastating that would be a red Line in
the Sand like you can it's a balancing
act we're giving Ukraine we're giving
trillions of dollars but we're like
we're giving them a lot of Weaponry that
is working but you got to be careful
you don't want to completely devastate
their whole Army it's just a [ __ ]
terrible disaster man for the Russians
it's horrible they don't want to be in
there no those Russian kids do not want
to be in there I feel so bad let's which
one do we end up do we end on put your
vads away from making Kelly or biting
things let's put your badge weight with
Megan Kelly what she's saying
so this is an old thing Avi like that
she's referring to but Megyn Kelly
thought Jennifer Lopez
yeah let's let her say it like Jordan
Peterson listen to Jordan Peterson
subscribe to Jordan Peterson or anybody
else speaking out about these issues
they get
that's not the clip we can hear them
like Megan Kelly Megyn Kelly thought
Jennifer Lopez and Shakira wore outfits
that were too revealing when the singers
performed I disagree I disagree I
objected to like JLo and Shakira showing
their vag at the Super Bowl the former
Fox News Primetime star said on a
podcast like I don't want that
I think this is the clip here yeah
I object to like JLo and Shakira showing
their badge at the Super Bowl like I I
don't want that okay it's got to be
situation appropriate but I don't really
object to just like women embracing
their bodies or showing off their bodies
like the pictures you see Paulina
portskovic just had a really interesting
post she showed her bottom she looks
amazing
um what I object to back on the
Kardashians is the
unrivaled vanity
like the self-promotional out of control
focus on one's self I agree no I agree
I agree
we live in a time when when that's
that's considered uh Paramount I think
at the end of the day it sucks and I
don't think it brings out the best in
people
but that's what I think do you think
there's any tension in her being a
on-air personality who makes a living
off what's that appearance yeah Maine
Kelly and one reasons that was that
because she is not she's pretty [ __ ]
smart I'm impressed with me yeah I've
always been very smart I've always been
a fan yeah me too oh he's been a fan
she's sad she's a badass and she's uh
well grounded and she's very attractive
and she's very attractive she is sign me
the [ __ ] up it's interesting when people
go they're showing their vag and it's
like but they didn't they just like
Shakira I would marry and I think
Shakira's classiest [ __ ] yeah Jennifer
Lopez is very very much she's about
herself only she's such a classic
narcissist and you know she's been very
successful the question is 50. she looks
better than great Affairs and she's
older than that I saw her at the chili
cook-off and she loves it yeah she looks
fantastic but you know I don't think
she's they're like she's not wowing me
with her music or even her dancing
Shakira's no no Shakira does
okay McDonald's sells more hamburgers
than otherwise you can't what there
might be McDonald's makes a good
hamburger then what they don't make a
good hamburger compared they're compared
to who don't compare numbers
commerciality to someone who has a great
voice No One Compares success no okay no
so so okay so that's the metric so it's
not alcohol it's about Artistry dude
how's JLo there are people who are
better artists she's a she's uh there's
better there's people telling them she's
not there's nothing JLo has ever done
artistically ever that would be
considered
um original okay what's your care is
Shakira is a better singer and Dancer
hold on but she's done stuff
artistically that's original I don't
know they're both pop music I don't know
but Shakira has a better by far a better
voice than JLo and I don't think anybody
that sings Would disagree with that you
can't just go by how many records she
sold but she still beats her with
records Shakira still beats her yeah
she's cute they're both huge but
Jennifer Lopez to me has always been
um just I I mean I just think here's
what I fall short for me here's my thing
I'm a fan of JLo and everywhere but are
you a fan what do you mean I like JLo
but what do you mean what do you mean
like what do I mean why are you a fan of
scared calm down dude no you're not sure
agent here's my other thing I don't give
a [ __ ] but if you want to argue argue
all [ __ ] day well that's all right so
calm down why do you like here's the
thing Adele's better than both of them
correct wise
Shakira is pretty bad badass but she's
not an amazing voice as far as no hold
on we're not talking about dancing we're
talking about singing
not like the Del Brite no Adele is not
even close well no no uh Dale's amazing
but Shakira's amazing too they're not
even the same [ __ ] category uh nobody
would say that I don't know I mean I'm a
huge adult Adele compared to Shakira
Shakira can sing compared to Adele she's
like once in a lifetime [ __ ] voice
that was ridiculous yes she's great but
but Shakira so that's your point your
point is Shakira's better because she
has a more better voice right I think
Shakira is a more uh more of a artist
musician yeah sure yeah I would say
they're both Jalen should care the same
thing they're packaged they dance they
shake their ass they sell a lot of Pop
records Adele is an actual artist she's
not shaking ass shaking her tits she got
up one night only in Hollywood saying
just acapella oh I understand that's how
good she is
gonna do the same thing you're the best
apparently there's something
she's amazing she's not Adele but but
she's pretty amazing she's amazing she's
she's I think uh Shakira can do almost
anything right as a singer and she's
known for that but having said that JLo
is not has never done anything I have
ever seen acting wise or musically wise
that I think is even remotely original I
think what she is is just gorgeous she
puts out a lot of stuff and she has a
great energy she's charismatic she has
an energy she has a she's a business
she's also gorgeous she's a [ __ ]
she's also a dancer yeah I mean she's no
one I would say
Lopez Jennifer Lopez is really really
good at branding at being a
businesswoman and all that stuff so you
can't take away from the fact that she's
got this crazy Drive
intelligence no
no
but what got her to the dance you know
but she was never a great actress there
weren't a lot of levels to her just the
thing that blew her up with Selena yeah
well she's so good looking like I saw I
saw um an audition tape of hers
um that before she made it and she
didn't even get the job and you see her
in that and you're like well she's the
best looking woman I've ever seen in my
life she's saying something right
personally Jennifer Lopez like
personally as far as physically goes
that's my that's my almost my Mount
Rushmore she's one of the girls on my
own listen I'm not getting my car and
put any of their songs on no no
you're not no you're not but when she
was younger
forget it
yeah you you you give it all up that's
just for a Living Color you would lose
your mind for her
let me hear her sing hold on see I think
it's a similar comparisons like Britney
Spears and Christina Aguilera like
Britney's not a great singer Christina
Aguilera can say oh my god well Brittany
was bigger take this
I don't see why he moves me so she
doesn't have an instrument but she's
trying and she's got balls and when
you're that beautiful and you can do
that you're gonna she's [ __ ] good in
Selena outside that you know yeah
that's all
yeah
but she is beautiful
look at that
now do you know the words in Spanish too
Shakira zestoyaki or what's that do you
know the words to Shakira's estoyaki oh
yeah dude I know I know I speak because
she cares she cares Colombian yeah right
I know yeah her man cheated on it what
her man who's a Premier League soccer
player cheated on oh well he's a Premier
League soccer player he cheated on they
caught video on the beach Oh no you're
not a fan I'm not even a fan she uh she
went to UCLA I think or what was the
college she went to and she just was in
college and she never told she had a
different name and nobody knew it until
the Press was like yeah oh when she was
famous or yeah did she wear this she got
her whole degree and everything she's
tiny yeah the other thing is I love my
foot the other thing is I'm independent
yeah yeah
we've done 10 000 hours of podcasting I
had no clue you're the fan of Chicago
fan club can I name a song No No but
remember
South America
dude how's your Spanish
not bad I mean let me try learning these
songs she's I think she's
Colombian and Lebanese I believe that's
what her mixture is
and she's also in tax trouble in
Colombia she was nine million that's her
boyfriend right there that was her
husband they have kids together oh no
and he cheated on her you have to pay
taxes in Colombia but you know what
she's probably gone all the time he's
gone all the time it's tough
oh he uses he's a stuff look at how
beautiful those kids are I feel for both
of them in that situation and that's the
chick no she's accusing him of lewd text
messages oh it's it's uh that's not her
though he he got caught with like a
strip imagine or some [ __ ] like let them
kiss in there oh no wait that's the girl
yeah so it says it looks like a friendly
hug to me
oh my God nice to meet you in the water
you know what if they're just friends in
there by the way right there he was on
the beach like you're [ __ ] you see
that no there's even worse they're like
holding hands on the beach and yeah the
car would just looked like he picked her
up from somewhere maybe she needed a
ride yeah
that's a hello that's how Europeans kiss
that was the one that went pretty uh
crazy well you're [ __ ] I have not I
still haven't seen it one lip kiss here
I've seen a lot of European greetings
yeah but she's got her arms around her
in the water I mean oh I see so what my
girl's with a guy like that dude that
guy it is a primarily Defender we're
[ __ ] buddy if your girl starts hanging
out with the premier league play all
your fun they have all the money also
the best looking athletes you don't want
me you want medium and wrinkled what the
[ __ ] you don't want 55
hmm
I mean I don't have a secure fan I'm hip
to that huh I'm naming the security
she's all right I'm not listening to
music
you had no idea she got cheated on no I
had no idea she has tax issues no she's
like Wesley Snipes you know some stuff
that's just you know I I got a little I
got a little way too it's because of
Jayla I was like what and then I've
never seen argument I don't like him
like I guess I'll go uh what if you can
get this upset over she carry Halo in
the middle of it I was like no I said
Adele's better like well maybe I kind of
lost I lost interest in the argument
because I was like I don't really care
that me neither and I was like wait what
but Shakira does have an impressive
voice yeah she can sing she can she I
think they're both impressive I don't
the ones that one's more of a business
person yeah there's more one's more
relevant
hmm
Shakira just no Jayla she had a movie
just come out oh but and she just made
Ben Affleck you know one thing that you
underestimate sometimes is like the
whole Latin you know Community worldwide
like the Spanish you think like oh the
Bad Bunny whatever he wasn't on my radar
what he's got 80 million followers well
that's like uh Carol G like you know my
girl's Mexican [ __ ] she loves Carol G
even though Carol G's she's Puerto Rican
I forget what she is yeah that doesn't
kill me for not knowing I forget what
she is but most I bet Brian's never
heard of her she looks like lemon she's
coming so she looks like
um uh Khloe Kardashian but better yes
and she's super talented
dude she is
massive yeah you know so my girl went to
the Bad Bunny concert on Saturday night
at [ __ ] Staples or yeah whatever's
now bunny bad he see here's the thing so
when I give me Brian Brian said what's a
Bad Bunny right so that's why I get so
frustrated but he's Bad Bunny is hold on
the biggest artist in the world right
now won all the awards Bad Bunny yeah
bring up Bad Bunny how do I know not how
do I not know Bad Bunny
[ __ ] I'm old he's an actor too that's
bad he's a narcos oh so bad bunny is a
musician yes he's the musician right now
really he beat out like he beat out uh
Taylor Swift he's
um Colombian I think or what is he sings
in Spanish oh only yeah his English is
not good okay he did a song with Drake
though and Drake sung Spanish oh wow
Puerto Rican nose is all uh as well he's
also bi he'll suck your dick okay yeah
all right all right there you go cool
glasses how did you find this out bye
yeah he talks about it what an amazing
name Bad Bunny
I guess maybe the name was a clue huh
Bad Bunny Bad Bunny bad [ __ ] and your
girl went to Bad Bunny oh did she ever
murdered my kids have their merch
t-shirts and [ __ ] whoa oh boy no he got
caught making out with a guy at Club
okay
all good
and now did he admit it before was this
kind of like okay you can talk about
like like he's not he doesn't identify
as straight or biased he's like I'm just
gonna do he's fluid [ __ ] whoever kids
these days are fluent you know what you
say yeah this is how it is ask me ask me
how what what my sexuality is what are
you into [ __ ] people dude I just [ __ ]
human [ __ ] folks I like you all humans
yeah like I'll walk into a room and I go
I wanna I'll [ __ ] all of y'all yeah
that's nice that's fine you're fluid
dude yeah well now you I educated on bad
budding now I know Bad Bunny I'm the I'm
the American Bad Bunny
people are people are upset that he'd be
not like Taylor Swift and like the
weekend and [ __ ] he's massive whoever
those people are I have nothing in
common with because don't care yeah
yeah but if it's Shakira you're willing
to die in the hill I'll die in the hill
that makes sense you know what it is I I
have a thing I was mad that you got mad
that about Chicago I was like wait why
are we arguing I have a thing for her I
mean after you but not for JLo no I'd
fight you for uh Shakira I'd punch you
in the face and then let the chips when
she's single right now you might
I'm about to get married though Bubba
please here's the thing I'm about to if
also she could pay my my other alimony
in child support
that's a good point so now I got three I
mean she's in some tax trouble 9 million
in the hole that's no problem for her no
we'll just go on tour and we'll also
just pay those times her support Oh by
we all sell the merch out there I hang
up my microphone no more stand up and
I'm just I'm just like honey you want
some more do you want ice in that or
that's me that's me do you want coffee
right now can you imagine living that
life well your girl's just this pot say
you married J.Lo yeah
your career is cool yeah you married JLo
daddy she's doing concerts at crypto
[ __ ] com Staples AKA Staple Center
Lambeau Field she's all over semester
Square Garden your career she's like how
much you make yeah hilarious I paid my
dancers more yes
honey now she loves me right you say
honey but I need you on tour with me so
you have to stop your life do I get I
get to play with the kids all day and
and the dogs your housewife sign me up
you're a housewife I think I think at
this age I think you could do that at
this age you might be able to sign me up
because what I do is I would just say
I'm gonna be I'm gonna raise these
children to be X-Men but when you're 25
you think you know if hopes and dreams
you want to Shadow yeah when you're 55
it's like 55 yeah ride's over yeah I'd
miss stand up but it's okay not when I'm
traveling America now I'm the Hamptons I
would sip the best wine now here's the
thing though but dude and she's been
she's a tough one she's a tough they say
so she might scold me for not having she
didn't yell at you for the house not
being the way she likes it she's gonna
she's astrology for not having her Diet
Coke to a certain temperature she just
told you for not having the [ __ ] M
M's in one color
I'm pretty good though and I'd be our
protector no she has security so I mean
you can pretend that but the security no
you're not even you're not even
protected I'd be training sure train all
you want she's like very cool because by
the time maybe seals out front right
yeah
it might be a weird gig
well it'd be you'd really have to check
your ego well yeah and I think yeah I
would die
you'd be miserable yeah well people like
that women like that will leave you too
as soon as you no longer serve a
function they're like well this isn't
working for me
and then they're going to be [ __ ]
around on you
and you're gonna be home with the kids
and the dog well it's like sugar babies
I can pay in a price
yeah I had a woman when I was a young
man say that to me she was a doctor she
goes why don't you just let me take care
of everything and you can do all your
stuff uh you can do your tiger she goes
you can do your Taekwondo and have your
dog I remember that and she was 35 and I
was 22. oh we have we're friends with
his name who's dating a very famous
person and she and his first crew ever
took off I'll tell you afterwards way
before she's like oh let's just get
married you do your thing like you can
still [ __ ] around other girls but then
just quit doing comedy and you're just
going to be my guy like y'all want you
at home when I'm when I'm home on the
road when I'm on the road you do your
thing you don't have to come with me but
if you do you can help me sell merch but
I'll take care of every desire you have
you don't have to do anything I'll cover
all the bills and he was like oh I think
I know who that is I I think I know you
thank God he didn't do it because he's
funnier than that person way funnier yes
way funnier I know exactly now she makes
way more money even now but she's a
terrible he said he was like oh yeah
yeah no I mean look the hustle is real
it's not easy oh wait you mean I don't
have to go to Pittsburgh improv this
week it's not that it's not that if you
said you have to go to Fort Wayne
anymore no no none of that if you just
said this Brian you will never have to
take a shuttle
anywhere again you're never gonna have
to take a rental car if the Sugar Mama's
newest better that's how they guess
they'd like I'd be like no shuttles then
you never you never have to go through
the airport again and deal with TSA not
you're only gonna fly private and you're
never gonna take a shuttle I'm gonna
have a car name the car what car you
want waiting for you Mike okay okay I do
it
be tough not to yeah
but you never have to worry about
YouTube suppressing your videos ever I
will buy YouTube for you and you do
whatever you want I'm like oh
where are you going to be this weekend
this weekend I'm off my papa's coming to
town I'm doing sets around La but next
week back on tour San Jose glad you
brought up your Cara lover uh next
Thursday Friday Saturday when San Jose
San Jose Improv is next Thursday Friday
Saturday that's October 13th through the
15th the week after that I'm in Salt
Lake City Utah Wise Guys October 23rd
22nd come on out Salt Lake City and then
I end October in Calgary one night uh
Thursday the 27th I'm at the rooftop
downtown Calgary Canada that's uh
Alberta and then because that thing's
selling so well we added a show on
Friday so I'll be there Thursday and
Friday now trying to get back Saturday
morning so we do a fight campaign on the
29th
um for the Jake Paul fight and the
Calvin cater and Arnold Allen fight keep
you guys posted November San Antonio and
Houston heavy and then I'm in Jeffrey
Dahmer's Hometown Milwaukee November
18th through the 19th uh but uh San Jose
you're up next week Thursday Friday
Saturday I'm all over L.A Laugh Factory
improv this week get you some tickets at
thick boy.com uh Bridgeport Connecticut
Stress Factory Europe October 13 14 15
Bridgeport if you're in the tri-state
area come see Daddy Schaumburg Illinois
the weekend after that October 27 29.
Charlotte North Carolina Comedy Zone
November 10 11 12 and then of course
Naples Florida off the hook and Naples
is fine do we know if the hurricane our
boy Eric I checked in on him except for
Gina
um they made it I didn't get washed away
well Fifth Fifth Avenue or you know that
people were using boats to go up but
it's fine now it missed it missed them
it stopped where their restaurant was
good thank you it's out there dude it
was no joke Florida was no [ __ ] joke
I don't know I didn't realize it that's
why I checked up hi kids this is the
fine kid biggest Shakira fans of all
time we're out